FOR "DEMOCRACY IN PERIL."
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS IS "DEMOCRACY IN PERIL."
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING A LITTLE
DIFFERENT TONIGHT AND HERE IN
THE DAYS TO COME.
WE ARE TAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT
THE STATE OF OUR COUNTRY.
THE THREATS TO OUR POLITICAL
SYSTEM AND POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS
FOR REVERSING THE DIVISIVENESS
THAT IS TEARING AMERICA APART.
MAYBE LOOK AROUND OUR COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW AND YOU DON'T LIKE
WHAT YOU SEE.
MAYBE IT SEEMS SO BAD AT TIMES
YOU ARE TEMPTED TO LOOK AWAY.
NO ONE WOULD BLAME YOU.
BUT THERE ARE EFFORTS UNDER WAY
RIGHT NOW TO UNDERMINE AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY AND WE CAN'T JUST BURY
OUR HEADS IN THE STAND.
YOU KNOW WHAT A FAILED COUP IS.
PRACTICE.
AND THE MASTER MINDS BEHIND THE
EFFORT TO OVERTURN THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION GOT THEIR
REPS IN AND THEY ARE CHIPPING
AWAY AT THE INSTITUTIONS THAT
HELD TO ENSURE FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP WOULD TAKE HIS RIGHTFUL
PLACE AS AN EX-PRESIDENT AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN WOULD ENTER THE
WHITE HOUSE AND GET HIS CHANCE
TO DELIVER ON PROMISES TO THE
VOTERS WHO ELECTED HIM.
WHAT EVERY PRESIDENT IS ENTITLED
TO.
WHAT VOTERS ARE ENTITLED TO.
THIS SERIES ISN'T ALARMIST.
IT IS A FRANK EXAMINATION OF AN
ILLNESS IN OUR COUNTRY THAT WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO IGNORE.
WHAT WILL 20 #IT 2 BRING AND
2024?
WHAT IF TRUMP RUNS AGAIN OR
OTHER REPUBLICANS RUN USING HIS
PLAYBOOK?
WILL OUR INSTITUTIONS HOLD?
AND WILL SOCIAL MEDIA ALGORITHMS
UNDERMINE THEM, CONTINUING TO
AMPLIFY CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
PEDDLING THEM TO THE MASSES,
EAGER TO CONSUME THEM?
ACCORDING TO A RECENT POLL, 73%
OF REPUBLICANS STILL BELIEVE THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN FROM TRUMP
DESPITE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS MAKING CLEAR THERE WAS
NO WIDESPREAD VOTER FRAUD THAT
WOULD HAVE AFFECTED THE OUTCOME
OF THE ELECTION.
DESPITE COURT AFTER COURT
DISMISSING BASELESS LAWSUITS
THAT ARGUED OTHERWISE.
THE BIG LIE IS A CANCER.
SO HOW DO YOU CUT IT OUT WITHOUT
KILLING THE PATIENT?
IS IT POSSIBLE?
AS IT SPREADS IN ONE REPUBLICAN
LED STATE LEGISLATURE AFTER
ANOTHER, 34 NEW LAWS IN AT LEAST
19 STATES ACCORDING TO THE
BRENNAN SENT THEY'RE RESTRICT
VOTING ACCESS THAT COULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT VOTERS
OF COLOR.
IN PARTICULAR LEGISLATURES IN
COMPETITIVE STATES ARE MAKING IT
HARDER TO CAST A BALLOT.
AND KEY REPUBLICANS ARE GAS
LIGHTING AMERICA.
>> STATES ARE NOT ENGAGING IN
TRYING TO SUPPRESS VOTERS
WHATSOEVER.
>> SAYING IT DOESN'T MAKE IT
TRUE.
AS MUCH AS REPUBLICAN LEADERS
WHO SUBSCRIBE TO OR ENABLE THE
BIG LIE WANT FOR IT TO BE.
AND THAT CLUB IS LIKELY TO GET
BIGGER.
ACCORDING TO A "THE WASHINGTON
POST" TALLY AT LEAST 163 BIG LIE
REPUBLICANS ARE RUNNING FOR
STATE OR NATIONAL OFFICE,
POSITIONS THAT IN MANY CASES
WOULD GIVE THEM AUTHORITY OR
INFLUENCE OVER THE
ADMINISTRATION OF ELECTIONS.
THE LIST INCLUDES 69 CANDIDATES
FOR GOVERNOR IN 30 STATES AS
WELL AS 55 CANDIDATES FOR THE
U.S. SENATE.
13 CANDIDATES FOR STATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
18 CANDIDATES FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE.
THE REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS WHO
AREN'T SELLING OR ENABLING THE
BIG LIE ARE ON AN ISLAND AND A
LIGHTLY POPULATED ONE AT THAT.
THE TEN HOUSE REPUBLICANS WHO
VOTED TO IMPEACH TRUMP AFTER THE
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL BY HIS
SUPPORTERS ARE FACING PRIMARY
CHALLENGES OR GETTING OUT OF
CONGRESS ENTIRELY.
MEANWHILE, STATE LEGISLATURES
DOMINATED BY REPUBLICANS ARE
DRAWING CONGRESSIONAL MAPS THAT
LOOK LIKE AMOEBAS.
GERRYMANDERING THEIR STATES INTO
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS THAT ARE
EASY FOR THEIR PARTY TO HOLD ON
TO.
REPUBLICANS CONTROL THE
REDISTRICTING PROCESS IN STATES
THAT OVERSEE 187 HOUSE SEATS.
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE PROCESS IN
STATES THAT OVERSEE JUST 75
SEATS.
OHIO'S STATE SUPREME COURT
STRUCK DOWN THE CONGRESSIONAL
MAP PROPOSED BY REPUBLICANS JUST
THIS PAST FRIDAY SAYING THE WAY
IT WAS DRAWN WAS LIKE A DEALER
STACKING THE DECK.
AND THEN THERE'S TRUMP HIMSELF.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT HIS
INFLUENCE OVER HIS PARTY IS
FLAGGING BUT IT IS FAR FROM
DEAD.
HE IS STILL THE LEADER OF HIS
PARTY.
HE COULD RUN AGAIN IN 2024.
AND MEMBERS OF HIS PARTY ARE
LOATHE TO CRITICIZE HIM EVEN
WHEN HE IS LEANING INTO
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ABOUT THE
FBI ORCHESTRATING THE JANUARY
6th ATTACKS AND BRAGGING ABOUT
HIS AUDIENCE SIZE THAT DAY.
>> EVERYBODY THAT I KNEW WAS
SAYING I'M GOING ON JANUARY 6th.
EVERYBODY.
AND THEY NEVER TALKED, BY THE
WAY, THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT THAT
CROWD.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
WALKED DOWN TO THE CAPITOL.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT THE SIZE
OF THAT CROWD.
I BELIEVE IT WAS THE LARGEST
CROWD I'VE EVER SPOKEN BEFORE.
>> IT WASN'T AND, YET, THAT KIND
OF LIE SEEMS ALMOST QUAINT AS
STEVE BANNON FEEDS HIS LISTENERS
THEIR DAILY RATION OF COUP PORN.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID OVER THE
WEEKEND.
>> THE DESSERTIFICATION PROCESS
IS REALLY KICKING UP NEXT WEEK
IN ARIZONA IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THE -- NOVEMBER -- THE GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF NOVEMBER 3